all right guys this is how are you hello
welcome welcome welcome lisa how are you
very well thank you thank you hi hi
everyone well thanks
good to see you guys how are you feeling
nervous as hell now who is the most
talented chef who is it
mum she's the only one who knows what
she's doing
meet tonight's family brigade the guru
murphys
mrs gurumurthy loves cooking almost as
much as she adores her competitive sons
political speech writer ravi
and news anchorman krishnan joining them
in the kitchen
is christian's aussie wife lisa at home
she does most of the cooking
these mummies boys have got to get their
ass into gear if they're going to cook a
three-course dinner
for 50 people all right tonight's about
perfection behind you there's 50
customers the objective across the
evening to make sure that every customer
pays for the starters will amaze all the
desserts rav what's the menu
uh rabbit is that it
rabbit give me a little bit more than
that uh rabbit risotto it's one
old rabbit wild robert risotto holy crap
sorry i tried to say [ __ ] that but it
wouldn't come out now no swearing your
mother's here yes yes
the rabbits and they've been poached
gently as you know it's a very lean meat
okay i'm gonna start off by sweating off
the shallots and the garlic yeah in
now the secret here is to sweat them off
with no color rice in
now you can see these little bits of
white grain in the center
that's al dente and then we had a hot
chicken stock one layla at a time
the secret is not to flood the risotto
if you boil it
it starts to lose its creaminess
you can see the texture now see yeah
yeah
we're gonna start seasoning uh the
risotto yeah lightly with a little bit
of parmesan cheese a little bit of
parsley in there now that starts to
darken
the risotto while garlic be very careful
this stuff very very strong
rabbit in or butter and our creme
fraiche
a little bit of lemon and watch as we
start to sort of
work the risotto but this really nice
creamy texture i'm just looking to
finish it off now
i don't want it too wet but look it's
just coating yeah yeah just looks great
on and then just a nice little drizzle
of olive oil cook with passion
they're gonna love it they're gonna pay
for it yeah cook without it
they'll be walking out right off you go
guru birthday brigade yes i'll order
four killers level 10 for risotto for
lamb for savion
four each one four one four
[Music]
yes chef thank you all right keep the
pan on the stove christian
that way it'll cook push down
on it too heavily yeah it bruises yeah
like that there
so try and keep it really nice and nice
garlic yeah you'll do six
kristen you got five ravi you got four
parsley
and garlic is chopped for both of you
behind here yes good good good um
watch out yeah that's fine [ __ ] it
you're all right that's bad fine [ __ ] it
don't worry you got a
[Music]
right you know how you um it no you
moved back and knocked him did i do that
yeah don't worry
don't worry yeah open that up golden
ramsay
open it up no that's not what you do
when you're tasting
oh you don't did you put it back in you
don't put it back
shhh ravi no double dipping yes yeah
listen
[ __ ] yeah pay some respect can i
keep it in the pan elise please
yeah how did you two meet uh we met
through friends at a dinner party
yes was it love at first sight uh it
yeah it was
it was last at first time it was lost at
first sight yeah
that looks really nice uh christian yeah
ravi really nice
check your plates good very nice right
ravi would you pay for that
uh yeah yeah so would i let's go yes of
course you would table three four
risotto
absolutely delicious they're not that
hot start acting like a queen move
[Music]
right janice reporter is rearing veal
cars for the f word russian i've told
her i want them tender and sweet
just like her
it's another glorious day in the
yorkshire dales mature mother janet
street pensioner has pulled out the
stops on her mission to raise two veal
calves for my f word restaurant
yes stupid animal that was really
intelligent wasn't it
she's even got her hands on a new 4x4 to
help her up to the barn
a third of a mile away
no janet's discovering how hard it is to
raise a young family
no christ what is that
i'm sorry you've got the trucks all they
do is poo
each day the cars get through 20 liters
of milk
there you go delicious slimy milk powder
janet's been reading up on how to look
after her little ones
one two three four yeah that works
really good
see any trouble i can hear you she needs
all the help she can get
i'm gonna have to make this mate taste
as good as possible otherwise i'll never
really end of it from gordon
god people do some weird things with
animals
every farm at worthy salt has a trick to
produce the best meat
each massage takes 20 minutes
massage with oil i'm off to
worcester to meet a guy who actually
massages his cattle
claims so it produces better me
craig i'm not entirely convinced that
meatless massage tastes better
craig has read relaxed animals from
swimming pigs
oh my word who just thought that pigs
could swim
to massage balls for over 14 years one
of his specialties is kobe style beef
which is massage daily
sometimes with a dietary supplement of
beer electric massager
it helps to distribute the fat
throughout the muscle so you're saying
that
janet get in there and massage them and
it's going to make a difference
i think so yeah it's gonna taste better
right better get massaging
holy cow with technique like that no
wonder she got through four husbands
how will the calves cope when she tries
it out on them
we'll find out later
working up the speed christian yeah
right clean the place now
oh what happened touch the pan touch the
pan yes
piping hard get it under water uh lisa
yes that's embarrassing he covers walls
and he can't even hold a pan properly
yeah
he's burnt himself quick go on very good
very good
now look at me easy clean your strip
down two more now
mrs guru murthy yes it's because you
don't know them in the kitchen they're
all burning and cutting themselves yes
you've got to move over and let them in
all right let's go
christian are you giving me the finger
last table yes table 12 yes
we may be one man down but we can get
through this yeah
can't we mr good murphy good go last two
well done well done you yeah we're [ __ ]
okay clear down get ready for the mate
yes
hi good evening how was the risotto
very good yeah um eating rabbit before
um no
good and we do have a pet rabbit not
after tomorrow
it's food in the garden um no it lives
in flat now i'm slightly confused um
your rabbit
is it the vibrating rabbit or
i've been sure your main cause as much
enjoy your rabbit yes
the rabbit risotto was fantastic
actually big explosion of flavours
lovely and fresh you could taste garlic
taste the herbs um if anything there's a
bit too much lemon perhaps
okay right now the most exciting part
yes the results yeah okay ready
here we go how many out of fifty are
gonna pay a 45
40. that's confident yeah i mean
seriously
seriously [ __ ] confident yeah mind
you he was out the kitchen for three
quarters of it so there is hope
yes the results are out of 50
46 out of 50.
yes seriously well done
next on the menu oh come on it's time
for janet to massage my balls
my size mr shane's brought on an attack
of the [ __ ]
jack and i get a ferris eye view of a
rabbit hunt
oh yes and i step into the ring with
boxer ricky hatton for the first round
of my healthy appetite campaign and get
more than i bargained for
i'm done
let's go plate out welcome back to the
f-word time for the main course
[Music]
herb roasted grump of lamb for me
personally one of my all-time favorite
cuts
delicious score and just slice
through anchovies rosemary
[Applause]
garlic stuff
in salt
pepper hot pan olive oil
all we can do now is color the lamb
olive oil rosemary anchovies
hot oven 12 minutes bang
absolutely rest
vinaigrette balsamic vinegar rosemary
mustard olive oil
lemon sieve
carve
that is amazing herb studied lamb with
warm vinaigrette
one more in there please wrap quick once
you've got color on there into the oven
yes
right leaves back out yep you tell me
what's wrong with that pan
for about the noise
really hot otherwise you're going to
boil the meat yeah right
guys we can do this how is the lamb
supposed to end up cooked
pink i think we're not doing mediums and
well done we're going to do pink yeah
we'll do it for 12 minutes now
yep it's got a rest don't forget yes
christian you're all right you look a
bit naked a long service is longer than
30 minutes
bulletin you know that's just 50 minutes
so good to see you doing the [ __ ]
full day's work
ravi yes think lamb lamb lamb lamb that
second pan should be ready to come out
excuse me
no stop this is the first one please
really important
if you get that wrong the whole
temperature yeah is going to go
right guys we're ready to plate up our
first dish now yes yep yes chef let's go
ravi i hope you're thinking about your
lamb in the oven yeah you're not
overcooking it yes yeah
good right all chinese recipes on the
website so log on and get in the kitchen
you're right who's doing the sauce oh no
no no no no no
never lifted they're coming out the
other one show me
under cold water [ __ ] it now don't lift
these pans up
ravi i thought you'd learn from your big
brother's mistake
medic please yes and mr gilmoreth they
look beautiful yes
really nice yeah well done let's go go
table later
huh now you're in the same position that
roughly was in earlier starters yeah
we're one man down yes
yep let's go right this year i'm going
to prove once and for all that healthy
food
can be delicious food
tonight i'm kick-starting my campaign
with a world-class athlete
who should know better this is the
poster boy for bad eating
ricky hatton otherwise known as
ricky fatten he may be a world champion
athlete
but his yo-yo dieting is legendary
ricky piles on an average of two and a
half stone after a fight
incredibly in 2004 he lost a total of 12
stone
the equivalent of his own body weight
you know from going to excesses with
eating to his body becoming you know
a fighting machine really but when he's
not boxing
he's binging he does love his chinese
he likes the spare ribs it is worrying
what the yo-yo dieting is actually doing
to his body
i've come to ricky's local capital buddy
box to see what one of the world's best
boxers
eats when he's not training god help us
now this is a local hangout right it
certainly is yeah this is where ricky
hatton disappears and ricky fatten you
know comes into shock ricky fatten where
did that come from
the press you nicknamed me ricky fathom
and they said oh he's too out of shape
he's not going to get fit in time and
all this and all i've done is is kept
proving them wrong
do you indulge in the kind of sort of
what it's like fast food junk
as a treat is a treat i mean when you do
a 14 weeks training camp
your menu is like the same thing every
day it's your protein shakes you know
it's your green veg you're starting and
you can't wait to finish it i wish i
could find the happy medium
as far as me eating is
does that come with a heart bypass like
most people
ricky associates healthy food with
boring food
i'm going to prove to him that he can
eat healthy all the time and it can be
just as much of a treat
as a fry up or a takeaway
to help ricky eat better first i need to
understand how hard he actually trains
[Music]
ah but don't [ __ ] miss i
got work tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
jesus christ oh i feel sick um
it's great now i've seen his world time
for me to get my own back
[Music]
i'm cooking the dish that's incredibly
low in fat but still bursting with
flavor
right when was last time in the kitchen
well last night i didn't cook cool [ __ ]
no you
worked in the kitchen to be honest i've
never really worked in the kitchen
skinless chicken high in protein low in
fat
this soy and rice wine marinade will
make it beautifully tender and full of
flavor
a touch of salt and pepper 10 minutes in
there
absolutely fine okay whilst i respect
you're in training but
you can make it a lot more flavoursome
as well yeah yeah i used to be
a fat chef yep just under 18 stirring
that way
bring some chicken stock up to the boil
kombu seaweed adds flavor
and it's rich in iron too a little bit
of ginger ginger adds a spicy kick and
it's great for digestion
and circulation nice and thin the
thinner the quicker it infuses
hey thank [ __ ] you're quick in the gym
see i need to get my own back hey 50 000
people
shouting yeah cheering for it who do you
listen to who can you hear in there
i mean mum really yeah and i think just
basically down to the fact that my mum
shouts some of the most diabolical
things you've ever heard in your life
be careful i forgot about that you know
again
that's going to make a big difference
yeah
the shiitake mushrooms shiitake
mushrooms crap name
delicious flavor into the stock as well
buy sesame seeds
toast them chicken in add miso paste
for extra body buckwheat noodles
they're full of fiber and quick to cook
right spring onions add some coriander
and serve so let's bring this into the
noodles
[Music]
adjusting everything you need from an
energy sauce as well
noodles anything ricky's been in the
kitchen longer than five minutes
[Laughter]
daddy made that you know that delicious
taste is very nice very tasty yeah
next time get him in the kitchen he
knows how to do it quite easily
and you know you've got it now you've
got it and i won't mention a word
to the family about the ginger
yeah kerosene pigeon land vested yes
where's your old pan for the sauce
i can get it back for god's sake oh rafi
why you put muffin with a carrot
oh my goodness oh we're losing it come
on everybody out
hey guys guys seriously concentrate come
on rafi
ah [ __ ] sorry all right what are you
doing
[ __ ] you now wrap sorry come on let's go
right we got one two three four five six
tables to go yes
yes brad where's your plates no one's
thinking their head
come on guys your brothers come on come
on come on come on come on communicate
right
okay good now here we go off there okay
mr murphy
that lamb is cooked beautifully yes
i'll do the honey i'll do the honey yeah
onto the hot plate right guys why are
you both pruning
the carrots on the plate hey guys put
the pan down let him do it
ravi come on why do you guys stop
talking to each other
what makes space you're standing there
like a shelter
come on come on come on come on table 11
yes good
don't worry cushion them on okay so
let's please mr murphy
please keep going
but the real star of this kitchen so far
is
right now more janet has she finally
lost her [ __ ] marbles
janna street pensioners facing up to
motherhood
every day can rain or shine she needs to
bring fresh straw and feed
up to the calves janet's trip to massage
farmer craig's balls
has given her a few ideas and now she's
learned that some people
even play music to relax their livestock
massage
time i've got some music
you may or may not like it
[Music]
now there's a surprise clearly they
weren't ready for that
but are they ready for this
[Music]
[Applause]
will janna's efforts at relaxing my
calves pay off with great tasting meat
we'll find out in two months time you're
getting the full greatest hits next time
you're [ __ ] miserable
bastards those nails are too sharp so
you you're stabbing me now jesus
still is breaking down the lumps in your
butt it's not lumps
your toes you know turns no it's solid
and you taste absolutely horrible right
so how are my babies
they are fine are they great i'm fine
now i had a bit of a hiccup
what happened i'm gonna be honest
my sex life isn't that [ __ ] desperate
one
had got pneumonia called the vet out and
he had to give him antibiotics he's okay
now
he could have died yeah so it was a bit
heartbreaking you know
yeah it's quite common there isn't carbs
in it to catch pneumonia
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's fine now
he's caught he's smaller than elton
yeah i know elton they are called david
and elton
and what does he call the mess because i
got a phone call two summers ago from
elton john to tell me he'd just
taken delivery of a brand new puppy oh
nice an
ouncation and it was very very noisy and
irritating so called it
janet and he held the phone out and all
i
in bed every night please god
make david and elton healthy
relaxed and gorgeous me for uncle gordon
i'm glad to hear it janet thank you
yeah how are we good yeah nice to see
you yes
welcome right how was your lamb the meat
itself was a really lovely bit of meat
and i just think it was ruined
because it was too salty the peas and
the beans were quite salty as well oh
really
and everything was salty eats we don't
add salt at home so that may be
everything in your life is bland enjoy
dessert there's definitely no salt in
there yes
good to see you yes thank you very much
the vegetables were really well done the
carrots with honey were lovely
um but the lamb was overcooked and quite
dry which really supported it for me
right christian yes is that the hardest
you ever worked that is the
hardest thing i've ever done probably
harder than sitting behind a desk and
read the news
welcome yeah yeah yeah right how well do
you think you've done
i don't think we've done well at all i
don't think it's good but here's the
thing
both of you started arguing you know big
brother syndrome little brother syndrome
why have you got that competitive street
in amongst you because i'm better than
him
i know i'm more successful he showed the
boys up
hands down nice surprise
oh come on 18 out of 50.
so you people requesting you that
[ __ ] with a capital s yeah 18 out of 50
not good enough for dessert let's get 50
out of 50. yeah okay
let's go that was so full on that is the
most full-on cooking i have
ever done i think i did quite well and
lisa did very well
i think the boys were a little unable to
cope with the speed of
doing things that was absolutely awful i
hated every minute
and i was about to punch krishnan by the
end of it
mom and my wife are still getting on
ridiculously well and me and my brother
are
bickering away blaming each other
next on the menu kate garroway tries to
get into pole position
in the recipe challenge who's had to go
on the top of the bottom i want to go on
top
and run rabbit run i take my son jack to
kill and cook bugs bunny
which means it stinks it's delicious
[Music]
[Applause]
right welcome back to the f-word now
time for the recipe challenge and
tonight's contender is kate galloway
she's been up since 2 30 this morning so
hopefully she's going to nod off and
then lose the challenge
are you ready i am what are you doing
i'm doing bread and butter pudding
which i think's a bit of a cough out
because it's not actually that hard
oh a very talented cook
and this is your best dish by miles
you're such a little minx that says
i cook a lot i cook all the time i lure
men by cooking but my husband says i did
on false principles because i
to cook them all the time we're dating
and i don't really bother
now so much because you know i just cook
for my daughter now crust off for me
otherwise i think it doesn't go all
squishy okay i'm using brown bread
i think brown bread is quite good kate's
making a classic breadboard putting out
a brown bread um i'm gonna do something
with leftover
panda chocolate cut them into sort of
four or five little slices and then just
a quick butter
on one side you're really quick
oh where's the recipe from mum mum mum
very much mum and my grandma as well
actually they've all done it
i'm now buttering the bread really badly
and now looks a little like a bit of a
bit of a sort of overwash knicker down
here to be honest
it's so nice to see you because they're
glamorous with the butcher's apron over
that wonderful dress you look great
thank you now it's rather sort of
asymmetrical it's a little bit
off-center you've got one in one outs
this is what it's like this is actually
a symmetrical top not the top of the
apron my darling
is amazing that's better right now
they're both back in
have you seriously been up to 2 30 this
morning i have that's when i get up yeah
i know
it's totally early isn't it do you wake
up derek that time in the morning or do
you just go why not to because he gets
really angry he's a bit like you
i was gonna wake him are you seriously
embarrassed to be married to a man with
the name of derek
it's funny but then when you get to the
room it sort of suits you really it's
kind of just
you have to sleep in a separate bed no
we're still we're still clinging on to
uh sitting in the same bed
how's the sex life 2 30 in the morning
there's not a lot the other day i'm
derek was saying there's not a lot of
that time
why am i talking about this i don't want
to talk about he's fascinating you don't
want to marry a morning person right
that way if you're getting up at half
too because there's not a lot of
opportunity and you don't really want to
talk or do anything but don't be
romantic at that
moment do you see what time's a good
time for sex i was kind of watching i'd
look at my look at my watch now
and that would be quite good but right
okay listen let me just
oh you're distracting me with your
that's awesome that's all i did
everything now i'm using a really nice
apricot jam i'm gonna put my epic jam at
the bottom and on top
yeah what are you using i'm using my
mum's orange marmalade it's really
strong ah did mom make it seriously she
did make it honestly yes she did i'm
gonna lie a little layer on the bottom
who are you on the sofa this morning who
are you with uh mr andrew castle andrew
bless him
do you prefer uh being with andrew or
ben all right i'm both ready
yeah yeah and is it true that you and
fiona don't get on anymore
what do you mean that's such nonsense
though we've always got on
and put a little bit of cinnamon in my
custard as well i know i have cinnamon
and mine actually
people love the idea of a big cat fight
between girls i often used to say that
we
used to like mud wrestle or something in
the morning seriously
well we should do shouldn't we don't you
think because people would love it i
would watch that
sir i'll get up at 2 30 in the morning
it would be great wouldn't it
oh look you're just coming around to
distract me even more it's looking
[ __ ] great for me
no don't don't let me stop something you
need to do the nursery i'm feeling
confident honestly
so you're putting the figs in between
i'm going to put a bit of fix and a bit
of dried fruit in between and then a bit
of sugar
i've made a really nice cinnamon vanilla
custard here
at the bottom of my tray cinnamon brown
sugar
and golden raisins i don't know going on
top because i don't want them burnt
and the idea now is putting half of my
custard in
and soaking it through the pan of
chocolate and then from there
spreading some really nice apricot jam
on the bottom
that stops it from drying out and keeps
the bread pudding nice and moist
i'm going to pour this over now it's got
eggs mixed up about
four but i'm terrible for not measuring
so i think it looks like it should be
about full for the size of this dish
extra thick cream that's it oh my god
that's so lumpy
jesus christ honestly it looks like
something out [ __ ]
a gmgb canteen holy crap
even the cab drivers don't need that
[ __ ] it's all about the taste it's all
about the taste
not a beauty
[Laughter]
with your mum's marmalade i'm so sorry
i'm gonna finish one with a little touch
of demerara sugar on top
and then a little bit of cinnamon yes
right just on top
oh dear i'm so sorry mum would you like
to go on the top of the bottom i want to
go on top
right get in there quick now they broke
over the oven for 10 to 15 minutes to
cook
kate has a quick nap i'm going to wake
her up and tell her she's lost
now it's time for dessert
it's a baglioni with peach puree slice
hot pan water vanilla
sugar blitz
chill creme fraiche
whisk
basil
into the fridge to firm up sebaglioni
egg yolk sugar water
peach schnapps whisk
beat over boiling water
[Music]
chocolate and finish with a delicious
longdeschat
and their sex on a stem
sebaglioni with peach puree
done
here's the thing yeah great start [ __ ]
middle
a high ending yeah yeah okay you're
gonna work with mum we're gonna husband
and wife today let's
train so no more rowing yes okay right
start getting your glasses organized
christian try and keep it in the bowl
yeah yeah
you need another burn yeah because i'm
not quite burnt enough to break
i think if we get out alive we'll be
doing well come on guys let me
show you okay we'll take it up from your
wife then come on don't stand there and
watch her
vaseline please yes so talk to lisa
who's putting this vaguely on who's
going to put the pure in
yeah um
turn your mother off yeah you're a brave
man
i don't think she'll take her trust me
you should leave that here
on the table mrs grandmother you tell
him ravi behave yourself
right i've shown you how to cook rabbits
here's how to catch them
[Music]
i'm with my son jack and we're on our
first ever hunt for wild rabbits
right ready rabbit is a fantastic wild
british game
farmers consider them pests but to me
they're a highlight on any menu
i'm hoping today jack will get to learn
how to kill and gut his first bugs bunny
which will cook together for him and his
mates after football practice
if we're quiet enough we might see some
of the rabbits pop out the holes
we're going to use the ultimate weapon
one that's been used to catch rabbits
for centuries
ferrets ferrets do move quite quickly
underground obviously they're they're
the kings of underground that's what
they're designed for
yeah if you don't want to keep them in a
box jack they take a long time they'll
just keep their ferrets down their
trousers
so you're fancy trying that no i
wouldn't
they've got very sharp teeth veteran
ferreters ben and guy
have found a large rabbit warren and
have been hard at work
so we've covered nearly one uh probably
20 holes here 20 holes wow
so they come out through the net and
then we'll pick it up as quick as you
can
hold it by its back legs and just snap
the head back and you'll feel the neck
break
oh ready yeah don't tell mommy okay
okay now to business we've put night
vision cameras
in the burrow and attached a mini camera
to the ferret
the rabbit to the surface and into the
nets at least
that's the plan but bunnies are fast
little buggers and they're hard to
catch there's got to be rabbits
somewhere down there
there should be she's just got to find
them at last
a rabbit in sight
we thought we'd covered all the holes
but they've got emergency x's at the
ready
[Music]
i can't help but swear i'm telling them
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that's it done jack's proved he can hunt
with the best of them
well done looks horrible
but has he got the guts for this make a
little cut with a sharp knife at the top
so what we don't want to do is cut the
guts open your hands in there
you pull it out like that you know any
of that and so the only thing left in
there is a meat
kidneys liver yeah sting which means it
stinks it's delicious
your little bugger right your turn here
we go wallaby sleeves good boy
good boy that's it that's it nice
straight in there nice
there you go hey you've now got a rabbit
caught one now let's go and eat one
shall we
yeah let's go thanks back home it's
almost time for jack's friends to come
over for football practice
to be followed by a meal of his first
rabbit he's ever cooked
first we're poaching a rabbit in chicken
stock season with garlic and rosemary
who's this little fella my old friend
where's the head
there good that there okay is it
shoulders yeah
here yeah okay here that's here
here yeah the muscle in here
that's how we took all the things out
yeah there's guts but look in here
pop that out smell what's that
that is his kidney oh yeah
[Music]
who this can you eat we can eat
everything you can turn the pepper
please
i'll put the salt we're just going to
rub a little bit of olive oil on there
and then jack what we do now is just
rub that through there gamey flavors
like rabbit go great in a ragu
whilst the rabbit poaches we're making
ours with pancetta carrots mushrooms and
courgettes
add a few layers of stock from the
poaching rabbit and just enough time for
a kick around
[Music]
ah it crossed the line referee
come on luke oh
hold on a minute oh
jack let's finish the rabbit off that
has poached now look at that little
taste i can't stop eating it
the poached rabbit just falls off the
bone perfect for shredding into the ragu
it's fit for any footballer nice
okay guys let's go rabbit's ready right
who's hungry smells
delicious nice lovely who likes some
more
lovely
to be honest i've been doing it so long
that nothing about the news fazes me
anymore it's probably a bit like you in
the kitchen because if you know what has
happened in the world chris
and you know what you've got to tell
people then you just tell them chris
you phased me in the kitchen yeah yes
yeah you got a whisk whether you've got
to move big boy yes
who's your favorite cook you are what
are your mother oh
[ __ ] what do you want to think
i want the recipe for that you know that
what does lisa think that you think you
prefer
your mother and my food to her yes i
think lisa has no pride on that's fine
yes good good pass it over and chocolate
on top please
yeah chocolate biscuits yeah chocolate
chocolate chocolate oh two brothers are
back together
this one's going
[Laughter]
why did you work that fast with the main
it's cool course nice to see you happy
yes now it's over
okay great get some water yes
[Applause]
unbelievable absolutely the texture was
amazing surprised by the basil
but it feels very light but actually
very indulgent i thought the combination
of both basil
and peach was really unique and
something i've never tried before
now time for the recipe challenge
results and the gmtv's kate garraway
to l-o-s-e feeling confident never going
to happen yeah
look i don't think we even need to have
a debate we don't even need to taste it
it's clear
a clear winner which is the best bit was
it the best bit
not a bit under there if you be
it's going to ruin my [ __ ] night okay
right jose
obviously come back with the right
result yes
oh it sounds no it's quite crunchy isn't
it definitely cinnamon if it turned up
looking like
that on my plate in a restaurant i don't
think i'd be very good
chocolate just seems clumps it's very
crunchy
it's still really soft looks a bit to me
like scrambled egg
it's a lot i'd say fluffier than the
darker one i think the fruit is lovely
right jose so how did it go five nil
what was it
well i have to say they lied both come
on who was it
i have to say gordon oh yes yes yes yes
excellent yours gordon very much the
chocolate flavor and the sweetness yes
but they did like to the fruit in kate's
one as well
what was the school 4-1
sorry okay we got one i can't blame them
that's not bad
you know it's not that good it's not
that bad yes
don't worry i've got a really nice
present
that's just me it's a lovely picture of
fiona bedtime yes
welcome back to you so far good to see
you well done
oh my god next on the menu
it's time for the news the guru murphys
find out if they've got the result they
were hoping for so
the number of customers paying out of 50
and lager expert kate garraway proves
her metal
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word time to find
out what the diners thought of their
zerbaglioni
right how was the dessert i enjoyed it
personally
i thought the bazaar couldn't be they
could have been cut better than it was
what do you like chop finely i think it
would have been nice
um it's quite sloppily if it's that long
it gets caught in your teeth and it's
it's so [ __ ]
chew it one day you won't have teeth
you're gonna lay them in
lovely food thank you very much um
you're not drinking wine tonight yeah no
i'm not i don't really drink wine no
i don't like the taste of it that much i
don't know a lot about it but i know a
lot about laga
right so i tend to stick to that and i
get don't get hangovers without this
one's really nice
yeah it's very nice one of your
favorites yeah you clearly love your
lager yes yeah i'm gonna put you to the
test to see
how much you know about it all right no
don't you piss okay
okay so small sips yeah sorry jose try
these i'll tell you which one you okay
okay what do you think
i wanted to lager is it honestly they
both longer try another one
well i like that one so number two yes
the one you prefer
yeah is the asda one of the cheapest
lagers in the country
there's nothing wrong with that 23 pence
a can
i may be cheap but i'm fun the one you
didn't like is the world's most
expensive lager
carlsberg yakubic vintage number one
they only ever made
600 bottles of these that's just that
you know how much it's good
204 [ __ ] pounds all right
okay next right well the humiliation
never end
which one of these two do you prefer
well that's fine
yes i wouldn't send that back no
i thought that was going to taste all
hoppy i think i've been picked number
one yeah
the one that you prefer champagne lager
one of the refined
glasses of lager just funny really nice
i'm a bit of an old snack maybe there's
champagne
i come out with class the one you didn't
like yeah mama mia pizza beer yeah it's
disgusting yeah
tomato organo basil why would anybody
bother
oregano and nag you don't need to do it
don't mess it up eat the pizza with the
lager don't put it in it
it's silly you put it back at the end
only one more thing to go
every true lager lover in the country in
fact in the world
should know how to do this oh stand up
oh
this is yellow yes it holds about 1.7
liters
now this man is an expert right yes he
loves drinking beer as you can see
all right guys give us a quick
demonstration with the twirling
[Music]
really important at this point to start
twisting the glass to think the world
record holder because
yeah does this in five seconds okay
take your time very very impressive that
releases the air
and it stops the sort of you know
payback at the end god
i want to marry you that's really
impressive
[Applause]
take your time you're a hero to every
female in the country come on
right come on to drive home
[Laughter]
you haven't even started
take your time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let me have a little go it's really hard
honestly
it's a lot harder oh you're just
[Applause]
i feel pissed
[Applause]
right jose let's go okay ravi how do you
think you did
i think we did pretty well in that last
course yes that's right great speed
great teamwork finally yes we split you
two buggers up yeah yeah
much much better much much happier with
it yeah if they don't want to pay for it
they're miserable
so-and-so yes so the number of customers
paying out of 50
37 out of 50. that's more than double
your mane
listen great start 46 out of 15.
brilliant
18 out of 50 for maine that is [ __ ]
excuse me dessert yes 37 out of 50. good
combined you've got 101 out of 150.
sadly that's not good enough to be the
best brigade
we worked as a team it showed you bonded
and united yes and we've learned today
yes are you proud of them yes i am yes
i'm proud of you all well done yes thank
you very much
now out of the kitchen gates have a
drink yes basically
high five elise well done my darling
well done well done well done
you